you're at fort bragg
you you choose to go special ops 23
years you're in so i'm assuming the
first three years you do boot camp ait
all the things you do three years later
you join the special ops so kind of how
it happened
you know i went to basic uh you know
airborne i went to ranger training you
know so all of the advanced infantry
training yeah and then when i went to
special operations then that's did you
do special forces or special forces okay
and what was your mo what were you in 18
delta i was 18 bravo what started 18 fox
and then zulu got it did you were you
part of special ops with delta or was it
special more special forces
i was in the unit for eight years
you weren't a unit for a yes i was a
direct support asset to the unit
conducting the low vis reconnaissance so
basically i was the guy who would go
around uh work with dcia yep the uh at
the embassies we will go and we'll find
fix and finish the enemy
abroad what were some places you were
deployed yemen uh southern thailand
libya
niger
i mean you name it i mean we
we were everywhere you know during the
global war what's the craziest situation
you were in when you were in the
military that you can talk about
you know every mission is crazy patrick
right uh you know obviously the gun
fights are always crazy but that that
gets played out almost every day you
know in in in a war zone
um
i want to talk about like okay so olivia
gaddafi dictator right so he brainwashed
his people you couldn't even have a
western education
and there was this uh
[Music]
we call them sources people that work
for the americans that provides
intelligence
and he was working for us and he was a
proud father he had a beautiful daughter
she was very smart
and she wanted a western education
you know so he would secretly get her
these books and have her read
you know and then one day the government
came to their door and drug their family
out in the street
put them down on their knees
and
they burned out her eyes
so
those are some things that we see
overseas you know
that people will never understand
um so those those are the crazy things
that we see is that people
get tortured you know in today's society
people think that you know we live in
america where everything is good and
danny everything's nice but in today's
world it's still savage so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]